Yeah,
my son,
my son's stubs,
his toe,
my heart drops,
man.
Yeah.
It's hard.
Man.
Falls on the ground.
Like what crazy did you ever feel so vulnerable and you're,
oh my God,
I'm terrified of the world now.
Terrified I'll be driving my car,
my get a slow down there.
Do you think of people different now that you have a kid?
Do you remember sent I'm way more.
I'm way more like I'm more scared of the world.
I feel like a more loving now.
I also,
if I have friends who are Shitty Dad,
I barely hang out with them anymore or hold resent against cause like that too.
That little dude and eat you so bad.
Yeah.
Now I feel the same way.
Um,
you know,
the thing is like,
I,
I feel sad for people who don't make the transition.
You know,
there's,
there's a transition to being a father that some people resist.
Yup.
Where it becomes the primary focus of your life becomes a big,
big,
big deal.
But if you make that transition,
the love that comes out of that and the change that it brings about in you and
the benefits for your child there so substantial.
Ah,
the,
I mean,
and it's so cliche.
It's the,
Oh,
it's the best thing I've ever done.
Straight up,
man.
I've had a cool fucking life.
It is by far the best thing I've ever done.
I want a squad.
I want the love I get from that little dude.
I'm like,
three of you would be even cooler.
Yeah.
You're going to have more,
100% yeah.
Working on it right now.
Yup.
Shooting live ones try,
man.
Fuck.
Yeah.
No.
This thing's working or whatever.
Fucking tail tail.
Yeah.
They say take zinc,
take zinc and magnesium.
I'm taking all these weird pills.
It's now get that to get the load that come.
Come you gotta save your loads too.
I know Jack.
A big day.
Yeah.
I went to a fertility clinic and they were all,
when's the last time you jacked off?
Like my girl?
Yeah.
I'm like,
Bro,
you're like,
I don't damn dude.
I never forget.
Never if I need to do it,
I don't need to look at me Bro.
Dude,
I had to go get,
I have to go give them a sample.
Yeah.
And just see how,
you know how my,
how my guys are swimming.
Well,
first of all,
it's not,
it wasn't very professional at all.
They're like,
go just go down there.
It was you grow with you when you got to give him a sample.
Yeah.
Man.
Tell to help you.
I,
she was like busy talking to the guy in there.
She was like talking to the doctor and he's like,
he'll just take you the back.
I'm like,
alright.
Yeah.
So you had to jerk off knowing your girls in the other room too.
So I walk into this room,
it's just Mexican dude.
Just like,
hey man,
just go in there.
Don't touch anything.
Just fill up the blank.
Got Egos and Oh yeah,
the porn,
the porn is on here.
They'll take your old style TV,
Vc v,
v VCR,
like old school.
And I'm like,
dude,
I don't need any of this.
I have a fucking cell phone
version of porn hub.
You fucking old dinosaur.
Fuck Outta here.
He goes,
we have magazines down there and with our 40 from the 70s what kind of bacteria
is Marty on those flights?
I know you get the fuck out of here.
Other dudes loads and lube.
I'll take it from there.
Yeah.
How sterile and I would have been super shady.
Have told my wife you're coming with me.
Do I felt like it was embarrassing to like,
like,
like I can them the thing in a bag and he just looks at it loads.
I'll do what if you open it up and smell it now?
You good man.
He lot of asparagus Bro.
And then when you're walking back to everyone knows that you're coming back.
You just get done Jack.
And we should walk up with your arms up in the air.
Like you scored the winning touchdown.
Yes.
Joy that fuck yes.
But what happened?
This is my thing.
This is my,
and I went kind of down to Eddie Bravo conspiracy.
I'm like,
what if for like,
damn,
your sperm is not good dude.
We get,
we're going to need more to take that to like he's a baby.
Baby's big dude.
We're going to use his genetics.
Make me sell that shit.
Black market.
There's a bunch of little browns running around.
You know what has happened many times more than once is these doctors,
if fertility clinics swap out,
other peoples come for their own and they have a bunch of their,
their own babies running around.
Like these people have wanted specific genetics and this one redheaded doctor
just shoot loads of the cups and then everybody's like,
hey,
why isn't my fucking kid have red hair?
The fuck?
Where's your nerdy man?
One doctor got arrested.
I think he fathered like a hundred children.
Oh my God.
Damn crazy.
Crazy person or awesome.
Give it back to the world.
I think he's just a crazy person because as a seed,
yeah,
he was running a sperm bank or a fertility clinic,
one of those and he just decided,
nope,
it's going to be all me.
All my loads out there too.
Don't you think for like a retirement plan for these assets.
The dude,
what does that image?
Oh,
okay.
It looks like a bunch of these two accounts.
There's a bunch of these guys.
It's not just one [inaudible] 90 to 92 no,
no.
I'm talking about like real resale to years in prison.
Oh yeah.
Shit.
He got to prison for that 280 years,
son.
280 years for jerking off.
Who could be seen to be saying,
oh dude,
don't you think you've very tired fighter,
let's say,
or athlete just in general like Hershel Walker's so and pay him $1 million for
him to blow a load into a cup.
Did you ever watch the HBO Expo say on Beek Crumb from the beak from yoga?
Oh yeah,
he's fucking,
he was here he is Indiana fertility doctor uses own sperm.
This is 2016 around 50 times papers say,
wow,
this is a recent guy.
I think there's been a bunch of these guys throughout history.
I think they should test every one of those guys.
They should make sure that they're not doing that.
Anybody running a fertility clinic?
It tickets.
It's like you get bored over and over again.
Guys are jacking off in the cops and you're like,
you know what?
Make my day exciting.
If I take out this load and put it in my room,
600 children.
There you go.
Wow.
Fathered 600 children and own fertility clinic.
Repeatedly using his own sperm fertility clinic.
He ran.
Hey,
that's some sketchy shit,
man.
I'm telling you,
this is a normal thing.
Guys are gross.
Guys are grown.
Men are gross.
Have a woman run that thing.
Women who were anti men less.
I swear to God,
we're not all like this,
but I get it.
I get it.
I really do get,
I talked about it in my special,
some creeps.
Yeah.
I mean I talked about it in this last special,
it's like I get it.
Yeah.
If I was a woman,
I'd be a feminist.
I get it.
We're fucking gross,
but not all of us.
Not all.
I would,
I would never jerk off in the 600 cups and pretend it was someone else's load.
Never even crossed my mind.
It's not me,
but I know that there's guys like that out there.
That does not surprise me in the slightest.
The fees.
I'm fucking fat gross guy with a little tiny dick and some woman with this
banging ass and little tiny waist.
Big Old titties comes in and she's like,
you know,
we were just trying to get pregnant.
We're really struggling.
So we decided to go the sperm donor route like,
hey,
we got a super athlete and he's a genius.
Another guy,
he's a doctor.
Use zones to father 11 kids.
Look at this guy.
Old Ass wigs were how old week had a bruise on his head?
Cheese is that,
that might actually be this real hair.
No,
let me see that now.
That's his hair man.
I don't back it up.
Back it up.
Pause,
go full screen now you can.
You can get away with that though.
I don't think so dude.
That's his hair that you can do.
Get weeks like that dude bro.
That's his hair.
No crazy.
He's just got whacked care
a wig and get it all grave fucked up is your nine
tonight and be like,
why do you want a wig?
What?
You just want your head to be free.
It's trying to fuck bitches.
Yup.
See as a problem.